[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de face au territoire sur TV5 Monde avec
nos partenaires Ouest-France Nice-Matin
France Antilles 20 minutes Centre France
la montagne et le magazine Le Point
récemment partenaire de face au
territoire vous pouvez retrouver
d'ailleurs cette émission sur les sites
internet de nos partenaires
coproducteurs bonjour Sarah elle a écrit
bonjour secrétaire d'État chargé de la
jeunesse et du service national et
universel merci d'être sur ce plateau
l'actualité tout de suite hier à Nantes
on va voir des images qui nous sont
envoyées d'ailleurs par nos partenaires
de Télénantes Jérôme des Ruy hier à
Nantes le village du service national
universel a été contraint de fermer ses
portes en raison de la présence de 150
manifestants venus perturber l'événement
il dénonce un embrigadement de la
jeunesse et la militarisation des
esprits c'est très fort on voit ces
images actuellement derrière vous pour
pourquoi j'allais dire cette réaction
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
en colère pour ce qui s'est passé hier à
Nantes en colère parce que la démocratie
ce n'est pas ça c'est le respect du
débat de l'échange et dans le fond ce
village et c'est mieux c'est la 9e ville
de France qu'il fait il s'arrête tous
les mercredis et tous les samedis dans
nos villes et dans nos villages dans nos
centres bourg pour présenter cette jolie
opportunité qu'elle est le service
national universel qui est d'abord un
service civile mais c'est la première
fois
qu'il doit fermer non pas parce qu'il
est une manifestation en face c'est
légitime c'est légitime de manifester
chez légitime de ne pas être en accord
ou en phase mais c'est-il légitime de
casser de violenter ou d'intimider
des problèmes liés à la loi sur les
retraites vous êtes victime de quoi
écoutez il se trouve que dans ma ville
je suis élu locale de Nantes je suis
l’une municipal je suis aussi je suis
aussi la députée de la circonscription
où il y a une partie de Nantes il se
trouve que notre ville subit depuis
maintenant des années des le samedi
pendant les manifestations du dimanche
et donc finalement il y a une sorte de
tolérance à manifester une chose et ce
sera toujours protégé c'est un droit
c'est la grandeur de notre pays mais
jamais jamais justifié une violence une
casse là ils ont privé qui ils ont privé
les enfants d'employés d'ouvriers ils
ont privé les Enfants Nantais de
découvrir peut-être une opportunité qui
serait heureuse pour eux ils ont privé
ses enfants et bien de découvrir
la jeunesse et de ce service national
universel quand je disais victime c'est
pas le bon mot est-ce qu'il y a pas un
contexte au fond qui est extrêmement
explosif aujourd'hui on voit que le
président d'ailleurs aujourd'hui parents
déplacement sur le thème de l'école dans
l'Hérault partout où il va le bruit des
casseroles il ironise le président sur
ces sur ses affaires là est-ce que c'est
la bonne solution de faire des traits
sur ça que ça est-ce qu'il y a pas au
fond un contexte je disais extrêmement
mauvais aujourd'hui qui perturbe tout y
compris les bonnes initiatives qui
pourraient y avoir ce que vous ne
ressentez pas vous il y a il y a
évidemment une colère
qui s'exprime sauf que ceux qui
manifestaient et qui ont fait que ce
village et ses nu a été arrêté et fermé
ce ne sont pas des jeunes ce ne sont pas
des gens qui manifestaient calmement ça
a été des violences et donc au point où
les personnes qui présentent ce projet
les associations qui étaient présentes
ont dû être par des CRS je condamne
absolument complètement
est-ce que vous trouvez pas que
l'attitude du président de la République
est inadéquate par rapport à ce qui se
passe
généralement vous pouvez parler ou pas
par exemple
je suis membre de son gouvernement et
même l'idole
forcément comme ça qu'il faut s'exprimer
on peut dire ça au président quand on
est secrétaire d'État ou pas on a le
devoir de tout dire au présent de la
République parce que au-delà aujourd'hui
de ma responsabilité et de la mission
qu'il m'a donné d'être en charge de sa
jeunesse écoutez aujourd'hui moi ce que
je vois vois c'est que le Président de
la République il ne fuit pas il est au
contact il n'a pas arrêté hier et bien
de discuter et d'essayer d'argumenter de
partager son son engagement mais
pourquoi nous le faisons nous le faisons
pour cette jeunesse de France parce que
dans le fond mais bien sûr mais parce
que dans le fond quand on fait parfois
des réformes est difficile la réforme
des retraites c'est une réforme de
d'effort ben nous le faisons d'abord
pour les plus fragiles et pour les
enfants sur lesquels on endette
aujourd'hui notre modèle
qui est sur notre plateau d'en face au
territoire voici François-Xavier
lefrandoestrance
bonjour vous êtes directeur des
rédactions de Ouest-France le premier
quotidien francophone du monde et on va
parler de ce parcours des lieux en
Loire-Atlantique bonjour madame
elaillerie vous le rappeliez vous êtes
élu du pays de Nantes de ce beau pays de
Nantes vous avez été élu vous avez été
réélu puisque vous avez été réunis aux
dernières législatives c'est
conscriptions couvrent une partie
urbaine et une partie rurale et les
Français vous découvrent à travers votre
carrière politique nationale vous êtes
secrétaire d'état depuis quelques années
ça vous manque pas le le terrain vous
n'avez pas marre un peu de de la
politique parisienne qui renvoie quand
même de plus en plus souvent des images
des images qui ont qui ont choqué tout
le monde des images de de enfin
d'inutilité moi j'ai fait le choix d'une
politique de territoires puisque j'en
viens je suis né dans le Loir-et-Cher
mais j'ai mon coeur à adopté Nantes et
Nantes m'a adopté et donc il se trouve
que je rentre en famille tous les
vendredis chez moi à Nantes j'habite à
côté de la Beaujoire et j'irai
évidemment ma vie parce que c'est ma
ville mais au-delà de ce retour du
vendredi samedi dimanche qui est celui
de la une semaine moi mon ministère mon
engagement ma responsabilité c'est de
faire que les jeunesses de France dans
leur diversité puissent croire en la
France l'aimer et donc pouvoir se
projeter avoir du boulot avoir des
études accéder au numérique permettre de
passer le permis de conduire découvrir
les engagements et ça ne se fait pas
depuis Paris et donc j'ai la chance
d'être parmi ces membres du gouvernement
pour certains d'entre eux en tout cas
d'être toutes les semaines et bien sûr
les territoires en déplacement d'où
l'esprit de cette tournée c'est nu qui
se fait principalement sous préfet les
territoires vous êtes une jeune
personnalité politique
et votre territoire sénante il y a des
municipales dans trois ans
Nantes vous parlez de fidélité donc
j'imagine qu'on vous allez vous avez des
projets évidemment pour nous notre
soirée aux audacieux c'est même notre en
réalité notre identité notre notre
slogan notre
notre leitmotiv nantais j'aime ma ville
j'ai été candidate aux municipale
malheureuse en 2014 c'était ma première
ma première candidature on en a une
deuxième avec Valérie Opel qui a mené
notre liste une liste d'unions
évidemment nous sommes au rendez-vous
des conseils municipaux et des conseils
métropolitains et nous proposerons un
projet un projet
d'alternantalement vous sépare de
Johanna Roland la mère de Nantes la mer
socialiste de Nantes fondamentalement
et le et le calme la fierté d'être
nantais ça veut dire quoi et bien moi ma
famille politique c'est la famille
centriste vous savez je suis auprès de
François Bayrou nous sommes des
démocrates on va chercher le consensus
déjà une élue de la ville de la ville et
de la métropole je suis déjà une élue au
moment où vous déterminerez alors c'est
ça la question c'est c'est toujours un
exercice d'union d'unité le travail ils
se fonde moi ce que je veux c'est que
nandre retrouve liberté retrouve le
rayonnement aujourd'hui c'est difficile
il y a du il y a beaucoup de vagalam on
voit des articles de presse qui parlent
de notre de l'insécurité regardez des
locataires
et je veux que ça continue je veux que
on continue à attirer des emplois je
veux qu'on continue à avoir une ambition
en terme de transport moi je veux que on
ait un RER métropolitain je veux qu'on
sorte de ce clivage autour de l'aéroport
qu'on réussisse dans le fond à redonner
vous savez cette envie d'être amoureux
de Nantes et de dire avec tellement de
fierté je suis nantaise et je suis fière
de l'être et pour ça ça passe par la
culture l'école enfin bref dans un an le
collectif à la nantaise on va écouter
Armelle le Goffin qui est directrice
adjointe de la rédaction du Point qui
est le partenaire de cette émission le
point elle a une question à vous poser
on l'écoute on revient à François-Xavier
lefran après
pour une enquête de politique révèle des
faits de harcèlement et de racisme dans
un centre du service national universel
des Hauts-de-Seine un commandant et un
lieutenant-colonel aurait eu un
comportement inapproprié votre cabinet
aurait saisi le procureur de la
République néanmoins c'est fait ne
risquent-ils pas d'entacher la
réputation du service national universel
ce que je peux répondre à Madame Le Goff
c'est très simple je suis d'une
intransigence sans faille pourquoi parce
que nous avons recruté pour les 50000
jeunes qui ont fait le service national
plus de 9000 encadrants j'ai eu
connaissance de témoignages qui m'ont
été rapportés effectivement par un média
le soir même le soir même je dis nous
avons écrit la saisine de l'article 40
c'est à dire saisir le procureur de la
République et saisir une inspection
générale pour mettre en lumière je vais
vous dire pourquoi je suis de cette
fermeté là un peu comme quand tu as
l'honneur de faire grandir les enfants
d'élever d'être professeur de servir et
d'avoir finalement ce qu'on a de plus
précieux nos adolescents et nos enfants
la responsabilité qui est la mienne
c'est d'être et bien dans une qualité
d'encadrement absolument essentielle
c'est pour ça que ma fermeté est comme
ça je voudrais qu'on parle des jeunes
c'est votre champ d'action qu'est-ce que
le service national universel que vous
défendez et puis que vous défendez
fortement enfin vous vous y croyez ça
fait des longtemps qu'on vous entendez
qu'est-ce qui fait que c'est important
pour les jeunes aujourd'hui ces jeunes
qui sont traversés quand même par
beaucoup d'interrogations de colère et
de colère authentique qu'il faut
regarder en face pour un tas de raisons
en quoi le service national universel
peut être une réponse à ce à ce désarroi
à cette attente
à cette colère
moi je crois qu'on peut dépasser cette
colère se désarroi en tout cas en ayant
conscience que on appartient un
collectif ce collectif c'est la France
aujourd'hui cette force d'âme cette
force mentale qu'on a et bien parfois
les transmises par les parents qui vous
font confiance et qui vous disent ma
fille mon fils ton destin t'appartient
tu vas pouvoir découvrir à partir en
Europe avoir des mobilités ne t'interdis
rien ne te saute pas mais en réalité
c'est aussi le rêve français c'est le
rêve républicain ça et donc permettre à
des jeunes de collèges privés de lycées
privés de passer plus de 15 jours avec
des jeunes de lycées publics qui
viennent de trappes de Nantes de Guéret
ou de Clermont-Ferrand un vrai brassage
mais territorial celui-là il est
difficile parce que le brassage social
est nécessaire mais nous sommes en train
de de l'améliorer avec les réformes que
nous portons avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale pour avoir encore
plus de mixité dans nos établissements
mais ce brassage territorial ce
sentiment d'être français de lever un
drapeau de chanter une Marseillaise
quasiment à plein poumons de se dire
demain et bien j'ai un pouvoir d'agir ma
colère je peux la canaliser en étant
utile pour l'environnement pour la
solidarité auprès de nos pompiers donc
peut-être même les réserves les cadets
de la gendarmerie ou encore au sein de
la SPA ça ça c'est changer en fait la
place du jeûne et la place de
l'adolescent de notre société et donc
c'est le mettre en position de faire
alors ça ça n'a pas de sens
national universel je rappelle pour les
téléspectateurs Armel logo du point à
une question supplémentaire à vous poser
là-dessus
en cas de général
isation
vous avez notamment déclaré qu'il
faudrait penser à la place de la
spiritualité dans le cadre du service
national universel
effectivement il y a deux hypothèses qui
sont étudiées en profondeur la première
c'est la généralisation dans le cadre du
temps scolaire c'est la appellerait bien
sûr à permettre et bien aux jeunes de
pratiquer leur foi leur spiritualité
dans un temps donné et donc de permettre
peut-être l'accès à des aumôniers comme
nous le faisons déjà pour le coup dans
d'autres dans d'autres moments de la vie
et si ça reste sur le temps personnel et
donc le temps des vacances scolaires
cette question est moins prégnante alors
là une magazine Le Point rapidement
cette semaine ce qu'il faut avec notre
argent bonne question toujours plus de
dépenses toujours moins de services
publics la une du point notre partenaire
d'en face au territoire François gaville
Lefranc la politique ça fait pas rêver
aujourd'hui on parle des retraites
depuis des mois on parle d'argent on
parle d'équilibre ça fait pas rêver sur
ce qu'elle travaille
l'environnement on fait pas rêver les
jeunes aujourd'hui les jeunes sont
beaucoup enfin les jeunes globalement
reprochent beaucoup aux politiques de ne
pas agir en tout cas de pas les faire
rêver et pas avec du vent avec avec des
choses avec des choses concrètes les
jeunes ne votent plus
comment on va faire dans ce pays pour
rassembler comment on va faire pour
construire l'avenir du pays avec eux
avec eux des gens qui ont quasiment
votre âge comment on va faire vous très
jeunes vous avez choisi de faire la
politique vous avez considéré que
c'était le chemin comment les emmener
là-dedans il va faire des affaires les
jeunes business aussi ils veulent ils
veulent trouver leur place en fait je
pense que on aujourd'hui il y a des
jeunesses elles sont très diverses elles
sont très pluriales et moi je le vois
quand franchement quand je suis en
Alsace où je suis dans le Var ils ont
pas les mêmes vies et parfois ils ont
pas conscience de la vie de l'autre de
la difficulté de l'un ou l'autre et du
coup ils se font fantasme d'où ces
points de rencontre ses souvenirs
communs mais au-delà de se souvenir
commun aujourd'hui le plus grand
reproche que fait notre jeunesse on va
dire aux responsables politiques c'est
parfois l'unification il te dit mais
vous êtes
inefficace et donc non impactant ou le
temps de le temps administratif le temps
politique paraît plus long face à
l'urgence climatique passe parfois la
précarité et un des enjeux principaux
c'est l'éducation civique et morale le
retour d'une éducation de nos
institutions mais aussi dans les
pratiques ça veut dire quoi très
concrètement quand on consulte les
jeunes quand on fait vivre finalement
cet apprentissage de la citoyenneté de
l'école avec je pense évidemment la
démocratie scolaire alors on apprend à
voter mais la réalité aux dernières
élections régionales ou qui s'occupent
d'abord du lycée et des transports vers
le quotidien des jeunes exactement 9 sur
10 ne se sont pas déplacés et donc ce
renouveau démocratique ça veut dire
qu'il faut réconcilier la démocratie
représentative moi je crois en somme je
crois au fait que des hommes et des
femmes décident de donner la
responsabilité à d'autres et bien de
porter leurs intérêts leurs paroles
les jeunes votent pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ou pour Marine Le Pen
aujourd'hui en termes nationales écoutez
pas un problème
fondamentalement ce qui moi me me pose
question c'est le premier parti de la
jeunesse c'est l'abstention et pas une
abstention simplement parce que l'offre
politique ne correspond pas une
abstention parfois plus profonde et donc
un des enjeux en gros vous savez à rien
les politiques non ils disent que c'est
pas suffisamment fort que ces
félicitations et donc pour ça il faut
répondre aussi à la mauvaise inscription
des jeunes vous savez dans notre pays 6
millions de mauvaises malinscrits ils
sont mal inscrits sur liste électorale
la moitié au moins de 30 ans et donc
quand une deux Ouest-France c'est une
passion la question du vote on le voit
là une nouvelle France avoir un visage
celui de Marylise Léon qui va
probablement succéder au nantais Laurent
Berger elle est la numéro 2 de la CFDT
favorite elle est sa favorite elle est
néanmoins elle est née au Mans et ses
parents sont finistériales donc c'est
une fan de l'Ouest et puis les les
piscines privées ce qu'on a beaucoup
parlé des bassines en agriculture mais
les piscines privées qui se multiplient
et le fisc est en train de regarder ça
de très près donc nous avons un dossier
sur le sujet voilà François-Xavier
lefrancier directeur des rédactions
Ouest-France le premier quotidien
francophone du monde et le premier
quotidien français d'ailleurs merci
François-Xavier lefranco producteur de
cette émission dans un instant de Nico
étant duplex et en direct depuis sa
rédaction de Nice Nice-Matin
[Musique]
bonjour de nicaro merci d'être avec nous
ce matin vous êtes tendus plex en direct
de votre magnifique studio plateau de
Nice-Matin et vous intéresser vous de
très près à Nice à la jeunesse et au
numérique
oui bonjour Sarah alors la première
question ce n'est pas moi qui vous la
pose j'ai sollicité le robot chat JP je
lui ai demandé quelle question
intelligente je pourrais vous poser
alors la voici comment le gouvernement
envisage-t-il de promouvoir l'éducation
et la formation des jeunes pour qu'il
soit mieux préparé à travailler avec
l'intelligence artificielle et en
comprendre les implications éthiques et
sociales alors j'aurais fait plus simple
mais je vous laisse répondre à la
question écoutez moi je crois que
l'essentiel c'est de ne pas laisser
l'apprentissage de l'intelligence
artificielle et de son utilisation aux
familles les plus aisées en termes de
capital social et donc faire que ce soit
populaire demain l'intelligence
artificielle va bousculer nos emplois
elle va bousculer notre forme
d'apprentissage elle va bousculer
d'ailleurs d'après un grand un grand
journal national plus de 300 millions
d'emplois dans le monde et bien moi je
ne veux pas que demain les enfants et
bien d'ouvriers de classe intermédiaires
soit à percutés et donc je considère que
c'est à l'école de donner ses savoirs
puisque demain ce qui sera le plus
important c'est comment on utilise cette
intelligence artificielle et on n'arrête
pas le progrès en face au territoire de
nikaro figure visage de chat GPT on
vient vous de nikao à Nice en duplexe en
direct dans un instant pour aller du
côté de Fort-de-France ou notre
partenaire France Antilles et l'image
que vous allez voir c'est celle de Cyril
Boutier qui est le directeur éditorial à
une question à vous poser c'est le même
groupe que de nikao France anti Fort de
France bonjour madame la ministre dans
nos territoires des Antillais de la
Guyane les questions de la jeunesse sont
des questions centrale tout d'abord
celle du taux de chômage qui touche
particulièrement cette classe d'âge avec
des jeunes en décrochage on peut former
mais aussi la question du retour au pays
pour les jeunes qui eux sont partis se
former en France métropolitaine mais
qu'il faut de perspectives ne reviennent
pas en Martinique en Guadeloupe en
Guyane et n'apporte pas du coup les
compétences que nos territoires
pourraient attendre
comment leur répondre comment répondre à
ces jeunes au chômage comment se
répandre à ces jeunes qui ne reviennent
pas au pays quel espoir peut-on leur
donner
il se trouve que j'aime beaucoup les
Antilles pour pour y avoir passé
beaucoup de temps il se trouve que vous
êtes allés en Guyane il y a pas
longtemps exactement
j'étais en Guyane j'ai passé d'ailleurs
la nouvelle année en Guyane puisque
j'étais avec les forces armées de Guyane
qui protègent nos frontières et
d'ailleurs je pense évidemment vous
savez au gendarmes qui est décédé
malheureusement à cause de leur paillage
illégal contre lequel on lutte pour
protéger la faune et la flore pour
répondre sur la question des jeunes la
situation de la Guyane est en différente
de la Guadeloupe et dans différentes de
la Martinique je lui ai donné une
réponse un peu globale mais chaque
réponse doit être territorialisée
l'essentiel c'est que chaque aucun jeune
ne soit obligé de partir ou ne puisse
pas revenir ça c'est l'égalité vraiment
dans son dans son chemin de vie
maintenant la Martinique vit un plutôt
une vieillissement de la population la
Guadeloupe c'est l'inverse il faut créer
des emplois des emplois de qualité donc
une économie de qualité moi je crois à
l'énergie de la force de cette jeunesse
antillaise en lui donnant les moyens et
bien d'entreprendre je pense à
l'expérimentation par exemple sur la
levée des freins bancaires
l'entrepreneuriat est riche maintenant
il faut le diversifier et c'est ce que
nous faisons avec évidemment le
développement je pense au service
civique à l'école le nerf de la guerre
c'est l'école justement c'est la
précarité étudiante qui vous intéresse
de Nico à Nice-Matin
oui on le sait la crise sanitaire a
accentué considérablement la précarité
étudiante dans une enquête récente
réalisée à l'Université Paris Nanterre
13% des étudiants déclarent ne pas
manger à leur fin et 1 sur 10 ça
explique qu'il a eu recours à l'aide
alimentaire sur la question de la
précarité étudiante est-ce que les
réponses du gouvernement sont
suffisantes elle continueront il se
trouve que il y a à peine quelques jours
la ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur
a pu annoncer la revalorisation des
bourses en profondeur c'est plus de 500
millions d'euros mais on se satisfait
pas simplement de dire nous avons fait
une mesure permettant à plus de 35000
jeunes élèves de devenir étudiants de
devenir boursier une revalorisation
globale de plus de 150 000 jeunes le
maintien du repas en euros pour
l'ensemble des jeunes qui sont boursiers
ou ceux qui en font la demande parce que
la réalité est que oui il est nécessaire
d'accompagner essentiellement d'abord
l'accès au repas on continue à aider les
associations d'aide alimentaire mais la
question plus profonde c'est comment on
fait pour que quand on est jeune quand
on est étudiant et bien le coût du
logement baisse c'est la première
dépense c'est le premier frein au choix
de l'enseignement comment on fait pour
que la tarification des transports
baisse aussi et comment on fait que pour
que le gel aujourd'hui des loyers
continue c'est ce que nous c'est le soi
que nous avons fait le gel des loyers
CROUS et dans le fond cette précarité
elle est elle est multiple je crois que
plus que jamais nous sommes aux côtés
évidemment des étudiants et on
continuera à le faire puisque une
réforme encore plus profonde et en
travaux avec les organisations
étudiantes syndicales bien sûr Denis
Caro
alors dans plusieurs villes les facs
sont bloqués depuis des semaines de
nombreuses étudiants sont privés de
cours et ça tombe très souvent début de
cursus sur des des étudiants qui ont été
privées de cours pendant la crise
pendant la crise sanitaire ces étudiants
ils s'inquiètent pour leur année ce
qu'ils ont ils ont d'être inquiets bien
sûr à chaque fois qu'il y a un blocage
il y a des conséquences des conséquences
sur les études et puis on va se dire les
choses à chaque fois qu'il y a un
blocage ça touche d'abord les étudiants
souvent les plus fragiles parce que
quand tu as la chance et bien d'être
encore parfois chez tes parents ou
d'avoir un grand appartement bien tu
étudies dans de bonnes conditions quand
tu es quand tu as suffisamment et bien
de moyens parfois tu te fais accompagner
pour rattraper le retard la réalité
c'est que manifester c'est une chance
dans notre pays il faut le protéger moi
pendant longtemps j'étais responsable
syndicale à la fac et puis après dans
mon entreprise donc je crois en la force
de la mobilisation syndicale ou même
associatif de collectif je l'ai fait je
l'ai fait moi problème mais attention
attention à ne pas impacter dans la
durée c'est pour ça que moi j'appelle
vraiment les jeunes à débattre à faire
des propositions à continuer c'est ce
que nous faisons hier nous étions
d'ailleurs avec la première ministre à
Matignon lors de rencontres jeunesse
c'est les CNRS jeunesse et les jeunes
venaient des battre en direct avec un
certain nombre de ministres proposer des
choses et c'est ce que je continue à
faire au quotidien dans mon ministère
parce que la jeunesse elle a une part de
réponse pour elle-même et je crois qu'il
faut faire avec elle mais bloquer ça n'a
jamais été une solution dernière
question de Nico peut-être
alors on a appris ce matin que
l'influenceuse Magali Berda déposé plein
de contre Twitter dans l'affaire qui
oppose au rapport bubal dénonce
l'inaction du réseau social alors vous
avez été vous-même confronté à la
violence des réseaux est-ce qu'il faut
faire en sorte de les réguler
effectivement le travail est lancé il
lance avec mon collègue Jean-Noël
Barrault pour sur la régulation en
réalité et bien et la modération nous ce
qu'on fait c'est que on donne les moyens
aux forces de l'ordre de retrouver les
personnes quand il y a des dépôts de
plainte nous travaillons aussi sur les
tous les réseaux sociaux Twitter
snapchat Instagram Facebook bien sûr
mais on fait aussi autre chose on a
réenforce renforcer on a réarmé j'allais
dire notre outil législatif il se trouve
que dans une loi qui date du mandat
précédent nous avons créé ce qu'on
appelle un nouveau délit qui permet de
dire attention c'est du harcèlement
c'est une corde ça se fait en groupe et
c'est pour faire craquer quelqu'un
volontairement les renforcements
législatifs que nous avons mis en oeuvre
nous permettront bien sûr d'être
beaucoup plus ferme sur les
condamnations ensuite la question des
réseaux sociaux c'est aussi la question
de l'accompagnement pour le coup des
plus jeunes je pense aux conséquences du
cyber-harcèlement faut pas oublier que
quand on fait des choses sur les réseaux
sociaux ça a des conséquences dans la
vraie vie ça peut mener au drame au pire
attention pédagogie et ce qu'il faudrait
pas enseigner en fait au plus jeune qui
ont pas forcément l'historique nous
avons tous sur la connaissance de de des
informations et de leur provenance
comment se servir des réseaux sociaux
comprendre comment ça fonctionne et
comprendre aussi les enjeux y compris
quand on parlait de violence énorme
est-ce que c'est il y a pas un problème
à l'école déjà est-ce que vous
réfléchissez pas ces questions là on
travaille bien sûr sur ces questions-là
il y avait de l'instruction civile dans
le sang alors on est en train de
remettre au goût du jour l'instruction
civique pour nos institutions et pour
notre question démocratique sur la
question des réseaux sociaux comme ça
parce que ça ferait un peu poussiéreux
moi je ne crois pas aux questions de
modérées modernité en changeant
simplement les mots je crois que c'est
le contenu qui compte et c'est bien
essentiel il y a une part de continuum
éducatif les réseaux sociaux c'est dans
notre vie personnelle dans notre vie
citoyenne la question qui va se poser
c'est comment on accompagne les
enseignants comment on accompagne les
jeunes et comment on accompagne les
parents et donc finalement un jeune qui
est bien accompagné par ses parents ne
va jamais faire de par exemple de
Revenge porn on va jamais poster de
choses qui lui sont reprocher aux
parents mais bien sûr que on peut
accompagner les parents dans le cadre de
parcours entre autres je pense
évidemment autant du collège mais on
peut aussi prendre des décisions assez
fermes je crois que c'est ce que nous
avons fait le choix de de faire au
collège nous interdisons par exemple le
téléphone portable voilà c'est ça
qui est notre invité ce matin merci
Denis Caro vous étiez en duplex et en
direct de Nice la Une de Var-Matin qui
est un des quotidiens qui appartient à
votre groupe et dont vous êtes aussi
directeur de la rédaction
alors la démission de vous l'avez vu à
l'instant voilà de Var Matin c'est c'est
le maire de Toulon voilà merci dans un
instant d'émettre korkmase de TV5MONDE
sera sur ce plateau
un article paru hier dans le temps qui
est le quotidien suisse aux interpeller
oui Macron n'a plus l'excuse de la
jeunesse le quotidien suisse se demande
si enfin le quotidien revient sur les
erreurs de communication d'Emmanuel
Macron en Chine et se demande si son
côté un peu disruptif qui pouvait
séduire à l'étranger comme au National
le temps fait référence notamment au
clip réalisé sur place qui était un peu
saccadé faussement décontracté
faussement est-ce que vous aussi vous
pensez qu'à 45 ans Emmanuel Macron ne
peut plus jouer aux jeunes que c'est
terminé vous savez c'est un jugement de
valeur que d'apprécier une publication
moi ce que je vois c'est un président de
la République qui est courageux en fait
qui casse les codes qui ne se résout pas
à ne pas transformer ou réformer notre
pays face aux transitions face aux défis
de notre temps évidemment la question
des relations internationales mais le en
même temps sur le sur la scène
internationale le en même temps est-ce
qu'ils font et ce qui fonctionne
toujours moi vous savez ce qui est qui
m'importe et parce que je suis
profondément patriote c'est que notre
pays soit et continue à rester à la
table des grands des grandes puissances
mondiales et ce que je vois c'est que le
Président de la République fait que
notre souveraineté alimentaire mais
militaire avec notre loi de
programmation militaire diplomatique
reste au plus haut niveau et c'est pour
ça que le Président de la République
continue à faire rayonner la France à
l'étranger et à l'international en
particulier on revient à des mettre
selon cette fois le média américain
Bloomberg la France aurait engagé des
discussions pour établir une nouvelle
feuille de route un nouveau plan de paix
avec la Chine est-ce que vous avez des
informations à ce sujet et manuels
bonnes serait en discussion avec ou en
guise il se trouve que c'est ses travaux
sont exclusivement réservés à la au
ministère des Affaires étrangères et
vous comprenez bien que la jeunesse que
je porte mais vous avez l'air au courant
les la jeunesse que je porte c'est
plutôt sur la question éducative des
mobilités ce que nous souhaitons c'est
vous savez relancer c'est ce que je fais
en ce moment relancer la coopération le
rayonnement de la France à l'étranger et
donc je relance le service civique
international européens plus
spécifiquement ou encore ce qu'on a
connu peut-être il y a longtemps c'est
vrai mais
l'instruction solide au delà
l'instruction européenne mais les
mobilités internationales je crois que
on est fier peut-être d'être français
aussi quand et bien on découvre le reste
du monde quand on se comprend et quand
finalement parfois et bien on a la
chance de pouvoir comparer et ça c'est
un des enjeux qui sont qui sont les
miens aujourd'hui alors floral Hernandez
qui rédacteur en chef de 20 minutes qui
est partenaire de cette émission à une
question à vous poser elle est inspirée
par le panel de 20 minutes moi jeunes
c'est un panel qui réalisait avec
l'institut OpinionWay bien connu et vous
allez voir cette rubrique le selfie dans
des 18-30 ans de 20 minutes qui est
assez populaire a repéré une question
que faudra Hernandez veut vous poser
Sarah elle a écrit secrétaire d'État à
la Jeunesse
selon le panel moins jeune de 20 minutes
et OpinionWay le selfie des 18-30 ans
pour 51% d'entre eux la valeur de
travail ne leur parle pas ou ne veut
rien dire comment alors qu'ils vont
devoir travailler jusqu'à 64 ans
réenchanter le travail
voilà question très claire moi je crois
que en réalité ce n'est pas tellement la
question de la valeur travail que de la
valeur du travail aujourd'hui cette
jeunesse je vous l'avais dit elle est
hyper engagée un sur quatre et engagé
dans un dans un dans le monde associatif
un sur deux c'est mobilisé politiquement
pour une cause quel que soit la forme de
son engagement et donc il veut être en
phase avec l'entreprise dans laquelle il
travaille et dans le fond c'est la
valeur du travail la rémunération bien
sûr mais le juste partage de la richesse
l'impact sur l'environnement l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes la lutte
contre les discriminations à l'intérieur
même des entreprises et donc ce n'est
pas la question de moi je ne laisserai
jamais dire que cette génération est
feignante ce n'est pas vrai cette
génération elle entreprend cette
génération elle est elle est courageuse
dans un monde qui est bousculant qui est
transformant cette génération les jeunes
son rapport au travail
est-ce qu'elle n'a pas changé son vrai
rapport au travail par rapport à des
générations précédentes avec le
télétravail avec les profondément
exigeante avant le rapport au travail il
faut peut-être parler du chômage
aujourd'hui les moins de les moins de 25
ans c'est quand même
17,4%, c'est trois points au dessus de
la moyenne européenne c'est énorme mais
mais c'est le taux de chômage le plus
bas depuis 40 ans et qui a réussi
c'était ce travail en profondeur c'est
le président de la République avec des
mesures que nous avons commencé il y a
plus de 6 ans avec Muriel Pénicaud vous
savez on a le taux de chômage bien sûr
que si chez les jeunes le plus bas
depuis 40 ans plus de aujourd'hui on va
bientôt atteindre les 1 million de
jeunes qui sont en alternance nous
sommes partis de 200 000 jeunes en
alternance et en apprentissage nous
sommes à plus de 800 000 en ce moment
contrats d'engagement jeune pour les
jeunes les plus défavorisés les plus
éloignés 300.000 jeunes ont signé un
contrat d'engagement jeune l'objectif
c'était de 400 000 il me semble non vous
savez la question plus chaque fois qu'on
permettra à jeunes de retirer le
chevalier comment vous comptabilisez
parce que finalement un contrat de deux
jours ça peut être comptabilisé aussi
alors quelle est la moyenne un contrat
d'engagement jeune c'est un compte c'est
un engagement
plus jeune à rejoindre ainsi que entre 6
mois et 8 mois avec une sortie
d'insertion professionnelle ou de
formation qui permet aux jeunes dès 16
ans d'avoir une petite indemnité qui est
de 500 euros au début parce que vous
savez que le grand débat dit il y a
quelques mois c'était ouvrir le RSA nous
on croit à la force de l'émancipation du
travail et on se dit à 16 ans à 17 ans à
18 ans à 20 ans et bien il faut t'aider
à commencer dans la vie permis de
conduire santé logement sous mais pour
autant on a l'impression que enfin c'est
pas une impression c'est quand même
sortie des urnes en 2022 Emmanuel Macron
sur les moins de 35 ans est arrivé
troisième sur le vote des moins de 35
ans il est arrivé troisième derrière
Mélenchon ou Madame Le Pen est-ce que
vous pensez pas que Emmanuel Macron a un
peu perdu cette jeunesse parce que
c'était pas les mêmes chiffres en 2017
donc là il y a un gap énorme ce qui est
certain c'est que l'abstention elle
s'est encore plus aggravée chez cette
jeunesse là et en particulier
d'abstention on parle des jeunes qui ont
voté pour la proportion c'est encore une
histoire de proportion là on parle de
sondage moi ce que je vois c'est que le
Président de la République a fait un
choix mais massif 12 milliards d'euros
avec un jeune une solution 12 milliards
investi dans notre jeunesse des projets
comme on n'a jamais mis autant de moyens
financiers mais les moyens financiers
vous allez me dire c'est que des preuves
d'amour c'est quelle place on donne à la
jeunesse aujourd'hui qui compte et cette
place et bien moi je crois que elle elle
est profondément comment dire exigeante
et c'est normal c'est une jeunesse à qui
on demande de vivre avec la guerre en
Ukraine une question sur la question
démocratique l'arrivée des nouvelles
technologies
je vous reprends vous parlez de rêve
républicain du collectif France il y en
a un dans le gouvernement qui ne vous
aide pas beaucoup en ce moment c'est
Bruno Le Maire qui a attaqué les
familles maghrébines accusées de
d'envoyer dans leur pays ce qui leur
reçoit ce qu'il perçoivent des aides
publiques est-ce que c'est pas un peu
dur ça pour le pactole vous savez les
publicains d'autant plus qu'il le dit
sans apporter de chiffres la question
n'est pas tellement la fraude sociale
c'est normal de lutter contre la fraude
sociale mais le dit sans avancer de
chiffres sans
je viens de ces familles maghrébines moi
j'ai grandi
au gouvernement
[Musique]
j'ai été naturalisée à l'âge de 3 ans
mes parents étaient marocains quand ils
sont arrivés sur dans notre sur notre
territoire et donc je suis très à l'aise
avec mes origines avec mon histoire le
propos l'esprit du propos de de mon
collègue Bruno Le Maire c'est d'abord de
lutter contre toutes les fraudes et
c'est un engagement du Président de la
République depuis le mandat mais c'est
au risque de rhumatiser une population
sans même mais des données c'est des
propos malheureux c'est dégage au Front
national sincèrement c'est des propos
malheureux Bruno Le Maire c'est son
engagement est né de en luttant contre
l'extrême droite je pense que voilà
c'est une expression qui est malheureuse
maintenant soyons très clair la lutte
contre la fraude toutes les fraudes
bancaires fiscale fiscale elle est de
14e fiscale elle est de 14 ans c'est
essentielle et même la les fraudes les
questions sociales oui bien sûr mais
toutes les fraudes et quand on fait la
police de la fraude c'est nous qui l'a
créons sous le mandat précédent on va
renforcer les moyens parce que quand tu
fraudes tu mets un coup de canive dans
le pack républicain donc la question
c'est pas c'est pas la question de
stigmatiser la fraude sociale contre la
fraude fiscale c'est toutes les fraudes
parce que quand on travaille et qu'on
participe au modèle qui est le nom de
notre modèle social et bien il ne faut
pas accepter qu'il y en a qui met des
petits coups de canif comme ça par sur
le côté en disant pas vu pas pris ça
c'est grave et ça ce n'est pas
acceptable mais ça veut dire qu'il faut
avoir la fermeté avec tout le monde
qui est notre invité ce matin on va
regarder la Une de 20 minutes notre
partenaire voilà un remède psychotope
principe actif de certains champignons
hallucinogènes permettrait de soigner
des troubles psychiques comme la
dépression l'anxiété et les addictions
c'est des sujets nouveaux ça vous vous
en emparez vous pouvez comme secrétaire
d'État oui je le fais d'ailleurs je le
fais parce que je vais vous donner un
exemple très simple c'est la question
des addictions sur toi il y a plus il y
a plusieurs types d'addiction alors sur
la marijuana non je pourrais tout à fait
transparente je n'ai pas travaillé sur
le sujet ce qui est certain c'est qu'on
voit de plus en plus de jeunes voilà
beaucoup on le voit d'ailleurs dans les
bilans de santé qu'on fait au centre du
service national universel entre autres
ça donne une photographie de notre
jeunesse on le voit aussi sur les
addictions à la pue vous savez les
fameux cigarettes électroniques très
parfumées extrêmement mauvaise pour la
santé donc nous avons lancé une campagne
de régulation de sensibilisation on le
voit aussi sur d'autres formes
d'addiction je pense aux jeux vidéos et
d'ailleurs on a été extrêmement ferme
sur le retrait d'une campagne de
publicité qui ciblait en particulier les
jeunes et en plus les jeunes des
quartiers populaires allaient pendant le
pendant les grands événements sportifs
les addictions c'est un drame et c'est
un drame qui touche tous les âges et
toutes les classes sociales donc plus
que jamais dans un moment où notre la
santé mentale de notre jeunesse est
quand même voilà plutôt impacté je crois
qu'il faut être extrêmement ferme mais
surtout très accompagnant et renforcer
les moyens de nos de nos services
hospitaliers
la jeunesse il y a quelques jours vous
avez donné une interview au magazines
Forbes et vous avez parlé ouvertement de
votre coming out on va pas y revenir
parce que c'est des questions très
personnelles mais juste une question
pourquoi le revendiquer au fond on a
peut-être l'impression mauvais vous
allez me dire que qu'on n'a pas besoin
aujourd'hui pourquoi on parle parce que
à la limite ça c'est contre-productif
par rapport à l'effet qui vous avez vu
vous avez donné 40 parlé tout à l'heure
vous avez été violemment agressé dans
les réseaux sociaux est-ce que c'était
un choix d'en parler parce que quel
problème ça posait ça c'est typiquement
c'est c'est le plus triste dans le fond
on fait deux heures d'interview sur
l'intelligence artificielle sur le SMU
sur la jeunesse sur la relation
française
pour la relation entre la France et le
Maroc sujet important d'amitié
montre-moi ça me touche je suis
binationale et dans le fond et mes
questions arrivent sur et Twitter il se
passe quoi sur les réseaux sociaux et
donc comme dans l'émission d'aujourd'hui
je parle évidemment des réseaux sociaux
et de l'importance de faire rendre la
distance et je dis simplement que quand
ça touche ma famille et bien moi ça me
touche c'est vrai quand je rentre le
soir et que je vois ma mère impacter ça
me touche quand je vois ma compagne
impactée ça me touche et là il se passe
quelque chose d'assez particulier le
journaliste fait le choix de titrer sur
cette information là mais est-ce que ça
veut dire que si j'avais dit mon
compagnon mon mari il aurait titré sur
son mari quand son mari est touché la
ministre et bien considère que c'est
plus impactant et bien non et bien non
il se trouve que cette information si
elle devait intéresser elle existe
depuis plus de 9 mois sur la Haute
Autorité nous sommes transparents nous
avons des obligations légales il faut
déclarer avec qui nous vivons il faut
déclarer quel est le métier qui était
passé inaperçu
autorité on ne peut mais on ne peut pas
faire on ne peut pas me faire le
reproche de parler en toute honnêteté
qu'en me pose une question qu'on me pose
une question je réponds et considérer
que répondre vos affichages lobbying ou
je ne sais quel expression que j'ai pu
lire c'est dramatique parce que dans le
fond j'aurais dit la même chose en
parlant de mon mari de mon compagnon où
j'aurais utilisé quelque chose de plus
non genre et donc finalement mon ami et
puis on laissera bien aux journalistes
de choisir le I ou le Ie ça aurait été
grave parce que c'est exactement ça qui
fait que des milliers de jeunes filles
des milliers de jeunes garçons
aujourd'hui et bien parfois vont
jusqu'au
jusqu'au mal-être jusqu'au sujet
de vouloir presque allumer un contre-feu
ou faire diversion mais c'est gravissime
j'invite toutes les personnes qui
avaient également parler de ça donc si
vous voulez on a eu l'impression d'une
succession mais entre guillemets de
révélation qui qui n'ont pas lieu d'être
à aucun moment si vous regardez
l'interview d'air j’invite les gens à
lire cette interview à aucun moment je
parle de ma vie privée parce que j'ai
fait le choix en 15 ans d'engagement
politique de protéger ma famille et de
jamais finalement la mettre en lumière
sauf que partir d'une certaine manière
un peu
bi en tête en disant regardez elle
utilise cela ou ceci où elle fait une
version avec ça c'est dramatique et donc
aujourd'hui et bien je suis chère si ça
a permis à quelques jeunes filles de se
rendre compte que et bien non on peut
être d'une famille maghrébine on peut
avoir aujourd'hui une vie normale sans
pour autant avoir de problèmes et être
ministre bien sûr mais franchement là
j'en profite peut-être quelques instants
pour les jeunes filles les jeunes
garçons dans notre pays quel que soit
vos questionnements s'il y a un pays qui
protège c'est un pays qui te
qui ne doit pas te juger quel que soit
tes choix et bien c'est le nôtre donc
juste ayez confiance parler ne vous
laissez pas ne vous laissez pas faire
merci Sarah elle a écrit secrétaire
d'État chargé de la jeunesse et du
service national universel d'avoir été
notre invité et bon vent à vous vous
allez te regarder dans quelques minutes
dans les pays du Maghreb et en Afrique
vous parliez de vos origines dans ce cas
merci infiniment au revoir merci
d'émettre korkmarès on se retrouve jeudi
prochain évidemment à 9h30 pour un
nouveau face au territoire les
programmes continuent sur TV5 Monde